hey youtubers is Charlie this week we
finally caught up with Simmons on agents
of shield and we found out what Krakens
been doing the interesting thing is that
even though they had a super-powered
comic book character in the episode he
wasn't even the biggest thing and I
really liked that they did that they
made Simmons the main character in the
episode so let's start with top five
moments then I'll do my review and then
I have a few announcements because today
is also arrow day so careful for
spoilers from the episode if you haven't
seen it yet I'll wait just a sec okay
everybody ready
number five kraken is stealing shield
agents did anyone else catch the
reference to sound of music in that
first scene it was the very good place
to start line that's from the doremi
song very sinister I like the way they
twisted that it reminded me of American
Psycho when Christian Bale was murdering
Jared Leto too hip to be square it was
just a really funny example of them
turning a really famous song on its head
there was a whole lot of Sound of Music
going on in this episode I mean that
story takes place in Nazi Germany Kraken
is a Nazi it makes you think of Clark
Craig is like the Christopher Plummer
character Captain Von Trapp like he's
trying to keep his family safe from the
Nazis I guess that would make May the
Julie Andrews Maria character but I
don't ever see her breaking into song
they did dressed Skye up kind of like a
nun with her black hood here it's just a
fun way to look at the episode music was
a big part of the episode too and Sound
of Music was a musical so it's all very
appropriate the Whedon verse has this
really interesting relationship with
music I mean if you're a big Buffy fan
then you remember they did the all
musical episode I don't think that
agents of shield will ever do a musical
episode but it did get pretty musical
this week Kraken was kind of a bookend
for the episode you know he opened and
closed it we're gonna see a lot more of
him in the future
just because Simmons is going to be
working directly with him aside from
that Sound of Music moment in the
beginning though my favorite part was
probably the big ocean at the end where
they implied you know they might be
brain watching Simmons number four
Donnie Gill aka blizzard is back I love
it they had some fun with the powers in
this episode and that they kind of
buried the lede a little I mean he
wasn't the biggest part of the story he
was like the MacGuffin like he was just
a device to move the plot forward so I'm
glad we didn't spend more time with him
than necessary you know yes powers are
cool but this was an episode all about
Simmons and Hydra so Blizzard was just
there as a way to explain how hydras
conditioning works it also kind of paid
off last week's episode we're absorbing
man got all creepy you know compliance
is rewarded clearly he has also been in
that machine so if you're confused
Donnie Gill had been Hydra the whole
time it just turns out that his
conditioning wore off and he ran away
the fact that they didn't find the body
at the end of the episode just means
that he's still out there like they
didn't kill him off at the end which
kind of ties back into the sky crossing
someone off story line number three sky
is trying to keep it together and learn
how to cross someone off the list it's
really all about her learning to kill
someone and deal with it they kept
repeating that theme crossing someone
off the list
I thought the watch they made her
where'd that one that tractor pulls was
a little unnecessary it was just a way
to show how she was handling things that
last scene when Ward told her about her
dad and the watch had a heart attack
that was basically her losing it I mean
she calmed herself down but she's just
trying to become a good agent like May
which requires control or compliance I
guess depending on which team you played
for I just love the way the team Hydra
storyline and the team Coulson storyline
mirrored each other this week it's all
about compliance and control it makes
you feel like everyone on the show has
an evil twin and it's all about finding
out who the evil twin is number two
Fitz almost kills Ward so I totally love
Fitz in the episode I did not love
Ward's performance and I think that's
how the writers want us to feel like
Fitz hasn't really had a confrontation
with Ward since the finale last year so
this was a long time coming but this was
a big Fitz moment not a big ward moment
I know a lot of you have theories about
Fitz maybe turning evil I don't
necessarily think that's what's going to
be happening this season and I think it
has a lot to do with what happened with
Coulson at the end he just had that dad
moment where he explains yes I'm keeping
things from you I'm your dad I'm trying
to protect you and deal with a ton of
other unrelated in the world
but you are an important part of this
team I actually kind of thought he was
gonna get Fitz a hug at the end of the
episode I do think that Fitz is gonna be
stuck you know with his brain problems
for most of this season but the
character will have to go through a
change at some point I keep wondering if
that's gonna have something to do with
the Hydra plot in the conditioning or
Skye's father and the obelisk characters
have to change though matter only has
two states of exist
it's growth and decay so either Fitz has
to keep getting worse or he has to
evolve somehow and evolve does not
necessarily mean something good like he
could get wrapped up in the Simmons
Hydra plot and something bad could
happen which actually leads me to my
number one moment
Simmons is Hydra she was by far the best
part of this episode they could have
just done the Simmons scenes and it
still would have been an amazing episode
I mean the rest of the episode was a lot
of fun but Simmons was definitely the
best the name of that song that she woke
up to is god help the girl which is kind
of funny because Coulson brought food
helping the girl
thus Coulson is kind of like a god he is
immortal inside the Marvel Universe so
you could say he does have godlike
qualities it seemed like based on that
last scene she's gonna stay embedded
inside Hydra for as long as possible
probably at least the first half of this
season I don't think that's gonna change
until crack and learn she's a double
agent
and I definitely think that's gonna
happen I wouldn't be surprised that they
did something like that during the
mid-season finale like team Coulson had
to fly in and rescue her but just expect
a whole lot more cracking scenes
whenever we get Simmons scenes they're
literally moving her upstairs so she
will be working directly with Kraken and
his second-in-command
it's like Simmons is getting promoted to
work inside one of these crazy Baron von
Strucker labs that's actually a really
interesting conversation because the
work that Kraken and Baron von Strucker
doing are way more advanced than normal
Hydra bases it's like that first Captain
America movie where the Red Skull said
that Hydra is way beyond the Nazis in
terms of scope Baron von Strucker and
Kraken are just way beyond the scope of
normal Hydra just pushing the boundaries
of science obviously we're not gonna see
Baron von Strucker until Avengers two a
Kraken is kind of like his character let
me know that what was your favorite part
of the episode and what do you think
that they're gonna have Simmons working
on in that upstairs lab just in general
I give the episode a solid b-plus for
amazing use of Simmons I'm really happy
with natasha Henstridge performance like
her character is adorable but she's also
one of the most interesting ones - it's
still pretty early in the season but I'm
looking forward to seeing how they're
gonna tie together the Kyle MacLachlan
Ovilus storyline as well as the Hydra
storyline obviously it's gonna have
something to do with whatever they put
Simmons on working like whatever the new
Simmons Hydra lab scenes are I also
think it's really interesting how
they're positioning
Colson as being like the dad of the team
like they do have a lot of fun with it
even though he's not quite old enough to
be Simmons father he still brings her
meal cooks her treats her like his
daughter I guess of all the team members
Fitz and Simmons feel most like his
children
Skye is also kind of like an older child
she's just a little bit more self-aware
I just love how willing Marvel is to
take this show into the Whedon verse
like all that sound of music stuff that
is pure Whedon right there next week
they're totally going full fan fiction
with Coulson and May and I am a hundred
percent on board with that it just looks
like it's gonna be crazy so because my
flash videos are always gonna be going
up Tuesday nights first I'll try to get
shield videos up as early as possible
Wednesday morning so be sure to
subscribe to get everything
the real big news tonight is that arrow
season 3 is premiering I will be live
tweeting so if you want to play along
with me the links for all my social
accounts are in the description but be
sure to check back after the episode -
because I'll be posting my video if you
notice recently Robert Downey jr. has
also been doing a whole lot of Avengers
Marvel Iron Man for talk you can click
here to learn what that's all about and
you can click here for last week's
agents of shield thank you so much for
watching so let's all high five and meet
back up for arrow tonight
you